elle et législatives en toile de fond
l'absence de l'ex président socialiste
rafael correa condamné pour corruption
son poulain andrés araoz représente la
coalition de gauche
autre figure donnée favorite guilhermo
l'assaut chef de l'opposition
conservatrice qui en 2017 n'avait perdu
que deux points au second tour face à
l'actuel chef de l'état lenin moreno un
dimanche de contestation en birmanie des
dizaines de milliers de birmans ont
manifesté à travers le pays qu'ils
dénoncent le coup d'état survenu lundi
et qui a renversé en scène sushi
manifestations présentées comme les plus
importantes depuis la révolution de
safran en 2007
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france sa progression
est redouté le variant britanniques
décidément vecteur d'inquiétude alors
que le nombre de contaminations
quotidienne reste sur un plateau élevé
entre 20000 et 25000 depuis janvier tous
les regards sont donc tournés vers cette
nouvelle souche de coronavirus elle
n'est pas encore dominante en france
mais pourrait le devenir d'ici au mois
de mars invariants plus contagieux qui
pourrait imposer de nouvelles mesures de
restriction dans tous les esprits leur
confinement toujours pas à l'ordre du
jour pour l'épidémiologiste arnaud
fontanet membre du conseil scientifique
les chances de contrôler l'épidémie sont
minces
il s'est exprimé dans les colonnes du
jdd le couvre-feu et les vacances vont
avoir un impact sur la circulation du
virus en france mais il ne faudra pas se
contenter des chiffres globaux pour
juger l'évolution de la situation les
mesures que l'on prend aujourd'hui sont
efficaces contre le virus de 2020
toujours majoritaire tout se jouera sur
notre capacité à contrôler la
progression du variant anglais c'est
désormais lui qui donne le la
et qui imposera de nouvelles
restrictions le cas échéant et en
attendant la campagne de vaccination se
poursuit avec un 3e romain d'autoriser
celui d'astrazeneca
les premières doses sont arrivés hier et
les premières injections ont débuté dans
la foulée un vaccin qui se conservent
plus facilement que ceux de pfizer et
modern a alors que l'union européenne
fait face à des problèmes
d'approvisionnement se pose aussi la
question de l'utilisation d'autres
remèdes russes et chinois le remède
russe footing et efficace à plus de 80%
on voit tout ça en images
[Musique]
si ce pique-niqué validé homologué par
l' agence européenne du médicament et en
france par la haute autorité de santé il
n'y a aucun blocage pour qu'il soit
diffusé
s'il correspond aux normes scientifiques
et aux exigences de robustesse et de
contrôle qui s'impose en europe
[Musique]
il est presque sûr que si ce vaccin
n'est pas approprié il facilitera
l'émergence de nouveaux variants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si en france l'idée d'un passeport
vaccinale fait toujours débat ailleurs
en europe
elle se concrétise la suède et le
danemark sont prêts a instauré cette
mesure qui permettra aux personnes
immunisées de retourner au restaurant ou
encore au théâtre et mesure loin de
faire l'unanimité
quelque 600 personnes ont ainsi arpenté
hier soir les rues de copenhague pour
protester
les manifestants s'étaient donné rendez
vous devant le parlement pour soutenir
je cite la liberté de choix et dénoncé
la coercition et la dictature du semis
confinement alors que les restrictions
sanitaires dans le pays sont prolongés
au moins jusqu'au 28 février
et qu'en est il ailleurs dans l'ue la
situation sanitaire certains pays s'en
sortent mieux que d'autres et décide
donc de faire preuve de solidarité
le récit de medias keffieh quentin
mauclair une situation sanitaire
toujours difficile en europe mais des
signaux positifs dans certains pays
en allemagne les écoles bars restaurants
et commerces non alimentaires restent
fermées pour contrer l'épidémie de kobe
19 qui a connu une recrudescence depuis
la fin de l'année 2020 l'exécutif
allemand avait opté pour un nouveau
confinement dès le mois de décembre des
mesures qui semblent déjà porter leurs
fruits
nous ne pouvons pas rester dans ce
confinement dur tout l'hiver
notre société ne le supporterais pas
bien il n'est pas possible de se
prononcer avec certitude sur la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouverons le 14 février
les chiffres sont encourageants nous
observons une tendance significative à
la baisse concernant les nouvelles
infections avec des signaux optimistes
berlin peut se permettre des initiatives
solidaires envers ses alliés européens
les allemands ont notamment décidé
d'apporter leur aide au portugal ce
mercredi un avion militaire est arrivé
sur le sol portugais à bord de
l'appareil
huit médecins 18 infirmiers ainsi que du
matériel médical la pandémie qui sévit
au portugal depuis quelques semaines
vous le savez probablement tous est
clairement devenu problématique
la situation y est incomparablement plus
difficile qu'elle ne l'est ici chez nous
elle peut se développer à nouveau et
c'est pourquoi nous sommes nécessaires
là bas et nous ferons de notre mieux
keystone une aide qui s'organise sans la
participation de la commission
européenne qui se dit néanmoins prête à
intervenir si le portugal en fait la
demande
de son côté l'italie a opté pour un
assouplissement des restrictions avec
notamment la réouverture des musées dans
le pays après presque trois mois de
fermeture mais les professionnels du
secteur restent vigilants c'est aussi
une forme de reconnaissance de la part
des autorités que des lieux comme les
musées peuvent garantir des conditions
de sécurité similaire aux endroits que
l'on considère comme de première
nécessité on ne sait pas si aujourd'hui
on assiste à une ouverture définitive
parce qu'il ya une variable qui décide
le virus dans la plupart des régions du
pays
les restaurants magasins et salons de
coiffure ont également rouvert leurs
portes un contexte d'embellie
alors que les populations de nombreux
pays européens sont toujours soumises à
des restrictions drastiques et pour
faciliter la reconstruction sociale et
écologique après la pandémie plus de son
économistes ont lancé vendredi un appel
à annuler les dettes publiques détenues
par la banque centrale européenne
inenvisageable a répondu sa présidente
dans une interview au journal du
dimanche
pour christine lagarde une telle
annulation serait une violation du
traité européen qui interdit strictement
le financement monétaire des états cette
règle est l'un des piliers fondamentaux
de l'euro explique t-elle décryptage
avec philippe béchade rédacteur en chef
de la bourse
au quotidien il est en direct avec nous
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur
rtl france ce soir pour qu'on comprenne
bien expliquez nous ce qui est en jeu
dans l'annulation de sa dette
ça fait débat et à une centaine
d'économistes qui se sont prononcés pour
expliquer comment une telle mesure
serait possible et christine lagarde
reddick part du classique in den c'est
quelque chose qui se rembourse si vous
amis les la dette nous a lu et defacto
l'héparine c'est-à-dire l'instruction
acheté cette dette et vous créez en plus
de ça un problème de crédibilité de la
banque centrale car ce n'est pas la bce
qui peut par exemple a mis les la dette
de la france cette dette est détenue par
notre propre banque nationale donc si on
fait ça tout seul dans notre coin on se
dit qu'il se décrédibilisent
voilà ça c'est la réponse de classiques
et on peut entendre un techniquement
qu'annuler une dette c'est annulé une
épargne sauf que vous pouvez remplacer
cette épargne effectivement part de
l'amener que vous créez or vous dis mon
dieu mais quelle horreur
la création monétaire c'est interdit par
les traités
c'est cependant ce que la bce fait avec
le constance et en renforçant à chaque
fois les niveaux d'injection depuis 2012
puis 2015 et puis depuis le no limit 2
mi mars 2020 sur lequel d'ailleurs
christine lagarde est revenue pour
expliquer 11 theron s'est réuni avec nos
collègues banquiers centraux et on a
décidé qu'on allait sortir le bazooka m
1850 milliards d'euros à disposition des
marchés et 2
conomie alors ça si c'est pas de la
création monétaire que c'est 1850 mia je
me demande en effet ce que c'est donc
mené de 6 et 8 bet
c'est peut-être pas joli joli mais c'est
ce que fait le japon par exemple depuis
trente ans et que je sache ça n'a pas
envoyé le yen dans les temps dit 'tout
rond' sion de l'effondrement de la
devise
voilà alors impossible selon christine
lagarde d'annuler à la dette des pays
européens en revanche la présidente de
la bce renvoie à un débat sur
l'utilisation de cette dette s'avoue 100
m le débat essentiel
oui bien sûr raison qui allons-nous
faire de cet argent
comment allons-nous de ressortir de
cette crise il ya beaucoup d'argent il
est gratuit
profitons-en pour faire des choses
intelligentes avec cet argent ça on peut
évidemment entendre l'argument sauf
qu'aujourd'hui le vrai problème qui se
pose c'est le creusement phénoménale des
inégalités ce sont les lieux boursière
et la christine lagarde botte en touche
en expliquant que finalement les
questions d'inégalité basse ça se résout
d'abord par des politiques fiscales
c'était en fait redistributive or on
sait très bien en france on ne peut pas
on ne peut plus augmenter la fiscalité
qui est déjà au maximum et cette
fiscalité elle frappe classes moyennes
et
les classes les plus défavorisées au
travers de la tva et autres autre type
de fiscalité auquel on ne peut pas
échapper 2 tandis que les quantités
phénoménales d'argent créé par les
banques centrales vont alimenter la
hausse des marchés financiers non pas
parce que l'émission de nouvelles dettes
enrichit les plus riches
non c'est pas du club fascicule puisque
comme le dit christine lagarde l'argent
est gratuit donc les dettes ne rapporte
rien en fait le jeu tout entier dépend
de la liquidité disponible et comme vous
avez plus de liquidités vous pouvez
prendre plus de levier pour acheter des
actions donc si vous en achetez plus
forcément et le montrent
et contrairement à l'épargnant qui
prépare sa retraite
ceux qui sont sur les marchés financiers
prennent leurs bénéfices tous les
centièmes de seconde
voir tous les millièmes de seconde c'est
à dire que tout l'argent qui vient
gonfler la laveurs des actifs est
prélevée au fur et à mesure tandis que
l'épargnant de long terme lui retrouvera
son argent effectivement le jour où il
le touchera sa pension donc là christine
bayart évite soigneusement d'évoquer ce
sujet et botte en touche en déclarant
que les questions de deux bulles etc
on les regarde effectivement mais qu' en
aucun cas ça mais ça ne va ainsi très la
bce a modifié s'applique de sa politique
monétaire tout simplement parce que la
plupart des gens sont complètement
ignorants de la façon dont cet argent et
créer de la façon dont cet argent
circule et c'est de la façon dont sept
en argent et stocker et il est stocké ce
qui s'oppose justement à ce que prétend
la bce c'est-à-dire que de l'argent que
l'on créé il est destiné à circuler à
créer de l'investissement or on
s'aperçoit que le taux de rotation
monétaire
ne cesse de ralentir à mesure qu'il y a
plus d'argent disponible
ça veut dire qu'effectivement cet argent
va se stocker dans des actifs dont
justement la profusion monétaire
garantie l'inflation presque presque
infini tout derniers mois assez
rapidement si vous le voulez bien au
sujet de cet optimisme dont fait preuve
au christine lagarde dans cet entretien
au journal du dimanche elle estime que
2021 sera une année de reprise quel est
votre regard est ce que ça suffirait à
sauver les économies européennes darmon
s'il vous plaît oui la reprise en 2021
christine lagarde a commencé aujourd'hui
son intervention par la seule certitude
que nous ayons c'est d'être dans
l'incertitude autrement dit on prévoit
trois buts ou 3 9% de croissance en août
l'année dernière quand on était à moins
10 on prévoyait quelque chose comme e +
6 ou plus 7 en 2021 or ça ne sera pas le
cas et j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que durant les quatre premières
villes de son intervention
christine lagarde a prononcé cinq fois
le mot vaccination donc pour elle
tout se résume à est-ce que la
vaccination et l'immunité collective va
nous permettre de redémarrer
si la réponse est oui son optimisme est
bien il peut le partager
si en revanche on s'aperçoit qu'au mois
de juin au moins au mois de juillet les
vaccinations non pas avancer assez vite
ou si elles elles génèrent l'apparition
de nouveaux variants vient la bce sera
amené à revoir éventuellement ses
prévisions mais celle là quand même
rassuré tout le monde en disant que le
bazooka
c'est jusqu'en mars 2022 et que on peut
encore éventuellement en rajouter si
jamais l'économie ne redémarre à ne
redémarrait pas aussi vite que le
souhaite christine lagarde qui
s'exprimait donc à également ce soir
chez nos confrères de bfm tv merci
beaucoup pour votre éclairage philippe
béchade rédacteur en chef de la bourse
au quotidien israël a commencé ce matin
un des confiné et progressivement la
fréquence des transports en commun
étaient augmentés les déplacements
peuvent désormais s'étirer sur plus d'un
kilomètre certaines boutiques ont pu
rouvrir comme les parcs nationaux et les
réserves naturelles
la majorité des commerces dits non
essentiels et les frontières du pays
reste toutefois fermé les autorités
avaient mis en place un confinement
strict il a été prolongé à quatre
reprises israël qui mène depuis décembre
une vaste campagne de vaccination c'est
l'un des pays les plus avancés en la
matière un tiers des habitants a déjà
reçu au moins une injection
conséquence les quatre co vider les
hospitalisations chez les personnes de
plus de 60 ans ont chuté de près de 45%
selon des études préliminaires
communiqués par le ministère de la santé
un jour de vote en equateur un scrutin
présidentielle couplée à des
législatives pour désigner celui qui
succédera à lenin moreno cesse candidats
sont en lice un record parmi les favoris
l'économiste andrée sarah hausse de
gauche et soutenu par l'ancien président
rafael correa a maille à soupe au lait
c'est le grand favori de cette élection
présidentielle en equateur andres arrose
candidat socialiste est en tête des
sondages avec 32% des intentions de vote
arrivé sur le devant de la scène
politique récemment le jeune économiste
était méconnu du grand public il y a
encore six mois le candidat de la
coalition union pour l'espérance est
soutenu par l'ancien chef de l'état
rafael correa
ce qui explique en grande partie sa
popularité son objectif rompre avec la
politique du gouvernement du président
lenin moreno à quito où il a terminé sa
campagne entouré de ses nombreux
soutiens
il a promis un scrutin en un seul tour
et une grande victoire populaire pour la
vie pour la dignité
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici et
c'est pour cela que nous allons
remporter une grande victoire populaire
ce dimanche 7 février
parmi les 16 candidats à la présidence
deux autres figures se démarque lierre
molas aux ex banquier et représentants
de la droite conservatrice se présente
pour la troisième fois la magistrature
suprême
il prône une démocratie totale et en
équateur d'opportunités comme un symbole
comme et family guy à la fin je serai
avec ma famille chez moi plein de paix
en attendant les résultats
ils vont être positif ils le seront
certainement le peuple équatorien on a
assez des quatorze ans de socialisme au
21ème siècle dernières figures qui s'est
démarqué de cette campagne
présidentielle
yakou perez boire temps belle militants
écologistes incarne la défense des
droits des indigènes avec son parti de
gauche pachakutik avocats de 51 ans
fervent militant des droits humains
il combat depuis toujours la politique
d'austérité du gouvernement actuel je
suis toujours un militant et je vais le
rester c'est dans mes gènes je porte ce
là dans mon coeur mais aujourd'hui la
préfecture provincial est pour moi un
instrument un outil pour défendre mon
peuple pour qu'il échappe à l'état
colonial et hiérarchique qui impose ses
décisions
le pays s'apprête à élire son nouveau
président dans un contexte d'endettement
et de crise financière aggravée par la
pandémie de coronavirus guillermo olaso
et yacou perez récoltent respectivement
21 % et 10 % des intentions de vote
pour l'emporter dès le premier tour en
dresse à rose devra obtenir au moins 40
% des voix un scénario peu probable pour
les analystes ce qui entraînerait la
tenue d'un second tour le 11 avril
prochain une quelles seront les
priorités du prochain président nous
avons posé la question à matthieu le
quang chercheur en sciences politiques
et grand connaisseur de l'équateur
premièrement gérer la crise
la crise sanitaire et ça ça va passer
autant par investissements urgents dans
la cité dans la santé publique mais
aussi par un plan de vaccination pour
toute la population est aussi
l'investissement dans des tests etc et
en même temps oui enfin il faut gérer la
crise économique sociale d'un coeur bon
ils font complètement changer les
politiques économiques d'un sens là en
décernant propose de de sortir du de
l'accord avec le fmi
guillermo olaso au contraire veut y
rester et jakub ps mon gros dit il va
falloir négocier une tentative de coup
d'état aurait été déjoué en haïti selon
le ministre de la justice une vingtaine
de personnes ont été arrêtées dont un
juge de la cour de cassation et
l'inspectrice générale de la police
nationale
le président fera fiable ce soir avoir
échappé à une tentative de meurtre
je venais la moise contestée est accusé
de vouloir prolonger son mandat il
également
plus tôt dans la journée il avait
maintenu qu'il lui restait un nom au
pouvoir alors que le conseil supérieur
du pouvoir judiciaire venait de
reconnaître la fin de son mandat
l'institution qui s'était alors déclaré
vivement préoccupé par les graves
menaces résultant d'une absence d'accord
politique
l'on redoute des violences sur l'île
réaction de jacques nessie politologue
et membre du laboratoire caribbean sur
sociale institutionnelle vient se
greffer sur un ensemble de frustration
de déception puisque on considère que ce
qu'ils donnent la république est versé
dans l'autocratie
depuis un an il dit il gouverne seul il
n'y a pas de parlement il décide seul
sans rendre compte à personne
exemple il a nommé le directeur de la
police nationale
seul il a nommé aussi les principaux
dirigeants de la bo national de la
réguler tahiti de la banque nationale de
crédit les ambassadeurs
otomo 10 et résidents qui il exerce seul
sans contre-pouvoir la totalité du bout
on a dit alan le pays qui est
traditionnellement dictatorial alors
qu'il y a un effort qui est engagée 186
vers la démocratie
donc cet exercice autocratique
contribuer à jeter le trouble a créé
l'inquiétude
l'étude qui va donc confier le facteur a
besoin pour l'investissement à la
contestation ne faiblit pas en birmanie
nouvelle journée de mobilisation ce
dimanche des milliers de personnes ont
protesté à travers le pays notamment à
rangoon pour dénoncer le coup d'état
militaire qui a renversé le gouvernement
d'aung san suu kyi lundi hier déjà ils
étaient plusieurs milliers à arpenter
les rues de la capitale économique les
détails à des gréements doucet
[Musique]
ils sont des milliers en cette fin de
semaine à défiler dans les rues de
rangoon trois doigts levés vers le ciel
le signe de ralliement des manifestants
ce qu'ils dénoncent le coup d'état
militaire du 1er février intervenus près
de trois mois après le raz-de-marée
électoral du parti de la démocrate
auxonne succi les protestataires exigent
la libération de cette dernière est
celle des autres dirigeants arrêtés lors
de la prise de pouvoir par la tâte matao
le nom de l'armée birmane
je me joins à cette marche parce que
notre gouvernement élu et est menacé par
les militaires la dictature militaire
n'est conforme à aucune loi le pouvoir
de l'état a été injustement confisqué
par les militaires il ne respecte pas la
volonté du peuple et je pense qu'ils
trahissent le pays nous allons nous
battre jusqu'au bout et aujourd'hui
notre révolution a démarré nous
manifesterons jusqu'à ce qu'ils libèrent
nos dirigeants nous exigeons la
libération de notre présidente
il nous voulons une véritable démocratie
nous nous battrons jusqu'au bout des
événements que se sont empressés de
dénoncer de nombreux acteurs de la
communauté internationale l'union
européenne condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté le coup d'état militaire
perpétré en birmanie il s'agit d'une
tentative inacceptable de renverser par
la force la volonté du peuple birman
lieu examinera toutes les options à sa
disposition pour faire en sorte que la
démocratie l'emportent elles la
communauté internationale doit parler
d'une seule voix pour exiger de l'armée
birmane qu'elle rende immédiatement le
pouvoir
les états unis défendront la démocratie
partout où elle est attaquée ces
développements porte un coup dur aux
réformes démocratiques en birmanie
tous les dirigeants doivent agir dans le
plus grand intérêt de la réforme
démocratique en birmanie s'engager dans
un dialogue constructif s'abstenir de
toute violence et respecter pleinement
les droits de l'homme et les libertés
fondamentales
les forces armées birmanes ont désormais
un objectif freiner la contestation
outre la mise en place d'importants
dispositifs de maintien de l'ordre plus
leur coupure d'internet ont été
constatés depuis lundi restreignant
notamment l'accès aux réseaux sociaux et
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout un questionnement
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre le manque dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas